Дайте знати, коли буде боляче.
Ви ще можете говорити?
У мене пігментний ретиніт.
Це спадкове захворювання, яке призводить до так званого тунельного зору.
десь до 30-35 років ще доволі непогано бачила
і навіть на велосипеді їздила.
Більшість пацієнтів, які тут в мене є, цього навіть не знають.
Коли я їм кажу, що я сліпа і це офіційно визнано,
вони відповідають: ми не віримо.
Можна дуже багатьох перехитрити.
Можна стати навіть чемпіонкою з хитрощів.
Звісно, я навчила своїх співробітників нічого не переставляти.
Бо я просто збожеволію, якщо мені доведеться
годинами щось шукати.
Якщо ти просто нахиляєшся назад і того, що тобі треба,
там немає - тоді починаєш шукати. Це просто уууух!
Мої батьки завжди підтримували мене.
Вони ніколи не казали, ти не можеш зробити це, ти не можеш зробити те.
Я б не зустріла свого чоловіка, якби у мене не було порушення зору.
Я завжди охоче грала в футбол.
А потім записалася на заняття з футболу для сліпих тут, у Берліні.
Це організував мій майбутній чоловік,
і я зараз там разом зі своїм сином
можу грати у футбол м’ячем, який деренчить.
Берлін дуже галасливий, багатолюдний, треба пробиватися.
Це дійсно виклик тут, у Берліні.
Я бачу світло, темряву та нерівні контури.
Тож, зараз, коли я у цій залі роздивляюся навколо,
я бачу вікна, я бачу круглі лампи на стелі як світлі плями.
За цим можна доволі добре орієнтуватися.
Сходи ж я намацую своєю палицею.
І, звісно, я знаю цю будівлю досить добре з усіма переходами і кутами.
Натомість зрячі тут завжди губляться і не можуть самі знайти вихід.
Вже у віці 11 років я вирішила стати адвокаткою
і вже ні про що інше не думала, лише про юриспруденцію.
Богиню правосуддя Юстицію завжди зображають із зав’язаними очима.
У моєму випадку через відсутність зору,
я, звісно, не можу судити про людей, виходячи із їхньої зовнішності.
Тож, я не відволікаюся на це і зосереджуюсь на тому, що мені кажуть.
Але, звичайно, я все ще не зовсім вільна від упереджень.
У незрячих вони свої, проявляються в дещо в іншій формі.
Приміром, коли не подобається голос або рукостискання.
Я не живий детектор брехні або щось подібне,
але у мене є відчуття того, чи кажуть мені люди правду чи брешуть.
Поки не можеш собі уявити, що незряча людина
може підніматися сходами, як можна собі уявити,
що людина, яка не бачить чи має слабкий зір
дає собі раду в професійному житті?
Я сліпа від народження.
Коли я десь в дорозі і кажу, приміром, я їду на роботу,
у відповідь лунає фраза: ви зараз їдете у майстерню?
Хоча повинні були б спитати: де ви працюєте?
Це насправді свідчить про те, як багато упереджень
ще потрібно подолати.
Шановний пане Шмідт, кома, ентер.
Шрифт Брайля, по суті, потрібен лише для коригування, я б так сказала.
Через озвучку я чую, коли слова написані неправильно.
Зараз я просто для вас вибрала цей рядок.
Співобітниця вже тут.
Зачекайте, я допоможу ввести.
Тут ви розумієте, що нічого немає.
Пробіл завжди без нічого.
- Коріна...
Він вже може це прочитати.
У цифровому світі, схоже, що сучасні технології -
це і благословення, і прокляття водночас.
Звісно, вже є деякі веб-сайти, які легкі у використанні для нас,
але все ще занадто багато таких,
з якими ми не можемо впоратись.
Коли, коли буде 221-й автобус?
Для цього я скористаюся мобільним додатком.
Ось підійшов 221-й.
Так, але тут він більше не відображається.
Каже, що наступний прийде із запізненням через 10 хвилин.
А той, що зараз підходить - його мені додаток вже не показує.
Я живу у місті, бо тут є мережа громадського транспорту.
Саме це робить мене мобільною.
Якщо колись зявляться автономні автомобілі
і я зможу собі дозволити таке авто, це було б здорово.
Тоді я зможу подумати, чи не переїхати за місто.